he Anderson are you ready to move on
whoa I'm flipping avenge well
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show attack
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Anderson PAC he's
a critically acclaimed grammy-nominated
singer rapper drummer and producer and
on November 16th he's dropping his third
studio album it's the highly anticipated
Oxnard
Anderson PAC welcome to the show it's
good to be here man it's dressed for the
occasion you know I see it I see it now
we don't have all of the fries for you
but we did bring all the hot sauces how
are you a spicy food I like spicy food
um but I'm not like a connoisseur and
I'm like a daredevil when it comes to
this all right we have the vegan Nuggets
on the plate ready to go from nervous
now man I really think about I'm getting
myself into but well there's no turning
back now these are all vegan or sure
they're all vegan positive I find with
the vegan Nuggets they're a little bit
grouse
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is gonna be the challenge right
here of just finishing these right what
does us so these days life is good for
Anderson PAC but I know that it wasn't
always sold out tours and studio
sessions with dr. Dre when you think
about your pre Fame career as a wedding
singer are there any ceremonies that
stand out ever have to deal with a
bridezilla or someone's drunk uncle
screaming requests in your face I've got
a lap dance at the same time playing the
drums one time damn yeah the girl that
was getting married to the wild in the
drunk we're playing there hopped on us
still kept the beat going and stuff it
was dope man we used to play all kinds
of crazy shows how dependent were you on
older women with money during the come
up cuz I get the sense that there are
some handouts from show from some
Shirelles bars man you know like their
cars in the in the in the wedding singer
stuff man like all kinds of gigs that we
did sometimes we didn't have money we
didn't have transportation we didn't
have places to stay we were just talent
so thank God for those people you know
how to women young women who supported
us through the music and support us
through those times we were just all we
cared about was just playing music bars
sleeping on couches so legend has it
your big break came when dr. dre heard
you on suede and then proceeded to make
you the most featured artist on his
Compton album there's so much mythology
around the genius of Dre and his ability
to pull things out of artists that they
didn't know that they had can you draw
back the curtain on his process at all
yes first off he doesn't do anything
that doesn't feel right doesn't care
about any of the hype he just tries to
hone in on a moment and just deliver on
the moment make sure you get it right
make sure you get it right he is he
hears it that way he wants especially in
his vocal producing he hears what he
wants so he's like I'm not sure I like
this even though words and stuff like
that as always it's that the technique
man I've seen people you know love it
and the people hate it is not for
everybody that's the part of his process
man I work on something for like three
four months write a song are just three
days and is done and then there's so
much fascination behind these music
juggernauts and how they operate in the
studio so what I want to do is hit you
with a few other Anderson Pak
collaborations I just want to know the
first thing that comes to your
when you think about how they work okay
Kendrick Lamar mechanic's assassin
meticulous technical TI south trap
southern very high-energy his music is
like a movement you know especially his
early stuff anthemic you know that's
what I think about when I think it's
eeeh chance the rapper chance the rapper
uplifting positive also technical as
[ __ ] a wide range of ability yeah I
think of a a man with the message and
then Mac Miller Mac Miller I think of
fun charismatic I think of all-around
MVP Khan a player you can do it he could
dish it rock he could shoot and he could
perform in the halftime you know he's
the one that the whole team looks to for
like that energy you know if he's
playing or not
[Music]
so you're naming your new album after
the city you grew up in shout out to
Oxnard California place you once
described as being best known for its
beaches Mexican broads and strawberry
fields so someone who clearly has great
insight I'm hoping to get an Anderson
pack visitors guide to Ventura County do
you have a go-to winery a go-to winery
he'll nob the liquor store don't wear
out five points leaves riding on winery
was it a point of pride for Oxnard when
an 18-foot Santa Claus was moved from
Carpinteria to your hometown I don't
know they were hyped about that but I
remember that Santa Claus because I
remember seeing it man but I don't
really know if like it could made waves
like that but maybe I think they're
probably more - when we finally got a
Krispy Kreme why do you think oxide
produces so many UFC fighters and boxing
champions as she does to do [ __ ] get
bored and then they want a fight so you
might as well do it and learn how to
really fight and grow in the gym and
make you know you know learn the art and
man we got some of the best man
scrappers if it wasn't for that you know
quite a lot of people be ain't getting
in trouble on [ __ ] who has more pull in
Ventura County superduper Kyle Madlib
are you come on
well you already know the answer to that
about to get the key to the city bro
shut up to the week I'll shout out to
Matt Liv is different cuz a lot of
people a lot of times if people come
from Oxnard Ventura but they don't
always rep after because you feel like a
big fish in a small pond out there so
it's like how to get to the city so now
it's great to come back you know but
definitely I got the most pool alright
so this next one is a mango and habanero
small axe instantly mm-hmm going up a
little bit mm-hmm
so can't have you in the seat without
discussing the Anderson pack live show
which has been described as a religious
experience by the Sydney Morning Herald
and as someone who has a deep connection
to the punk scene I'm wondering if you
have any thoughts on this growing trend
of mosh pits at rap shows are they up to
snuff rap entrap modern day trap is is
like the modern day Punk you know and a
lot of times in a punk rock show you're
not getting like ADA weights and she's
like real instruments and stuff and the
sound is thin but now it's like at these
shows I got these huge [ __ ] trap
anthems these crazy different breakdowns
and stuff and people just have like
don't know what else to do with their
energy but not everybody is there for
that especially at my shows like I got
like some soulful people right I got
people that just you know I work I got
kids me I got some that you know they
got this side shake I got like other
ones that just got their hilton hill
Zana [ __ ] and then the other percent
might be just white dudes you know and
they wanna [ __ ] come on yeah not
everybody's there for that so it's just
about keeping this song we gonna wash
off be careful and then in 2016 you open
for Beyonce at Dodger Stadium what if
anything did you learn about performing
from her because she seems to be
credited as being the pinnacle in that
Jonathan that show was a train wreck for
me that was one of the saddest shows of
my life we killed the soundcheck
that was the theme and shut out all my
bands I'd be killing the soundcheck and
then take a fat [ __ ] on at the day of um
the night of the show but we were a
hyper we were filling our selfie
Stadium [ __ ] soundcheck we met Beyonce
she came out to our side chick she was
so sweet like thank you so much oh then
we get a little crowd we start playing
first second song again boom my keyboard
players seen over his whole keyword
Falls come his whole rig just completely
Falls and destroys everywhere all over
the ground and this is big sound like a
feedback going nobody knows what's going
on everything slapping all over the
place and then the show was done hard 15
10 minutes was done stage revenue right
when I was going back to my dressing
room I remember seeing jay-z and like I
caught the very hand he just turned
around little I was like it's the rap
just did dipped off into the distance
this is almond milk because one let the
record straight
oh look it's all vegan today fire yeah
almond breeze mm-hmm
so good higher so good all right
Anderson we have recurrent segments on
our show called explain that Graham
where we do a deep dive and I guess
Instagram interesting pictures that need
more context I'll bust out the laptop
I'll show you the picture then you just
tell me the bigger story does that sound
good / alright laptop please Thank You
bell well first things first
paying homage to state property with the
Untied do-rag prop chain gang and then
the Iverson Jersey early how influential
was that era of hip hop inspired movies
I know that juice was a big deal for you
right I want to be a DJ I want to be
doing something a hip hop after I saw
that flick and I loved how they also -
what I love about that food is like all
his friends like there are brothers you
know come together they would go to one
one was cooking one was funny one was
more hot-headed and like I see that
dynamic with my band now too
huh shout out the free Nationals down
with the foot
there's a cat dander on this one we
didn't put hot sauce on this one see if
you were allergic puppies on that one
did you hurt yourself
dancin on the desk oh let's get it less
well no no no I didn't hurt myself thank
God cause like there was such like a
like heavy like camera crew like there
everyone was there so--but there's a lot
of people to like break out break my
fall and I like fell on cameras and
stuff so it was a soft landing but
sometimes when you hear your jam I can't
help it I gotta get on the good foot why
is it on loop and stop any time you come
in like this you gonna fall all right
bill we can lose that Anderson are you
ready to move on whoa whoa little taste
the middle sure yeah so these days a lot
of young artists get discovered by
posting popular covers on YouTube or
elsewhere on the internet and I want to
talk about what you did early on with
covers because you seem to approach it
more specific and your purpose can you
talk through the hows and whys of some
of the early songs that you covered I
wanted to take songs that were against
considered like alternative or white
people music I guess and change them
into like something that would be like
more soulful in the 50s early 40s that
were taking these records from black
artists and then you know what artists
would reinterpret them and then it would
get radio play all of a sudden if we
went from being like race records to
being called rock and roll you know so
my whole thing was just flipping that
idea of upside down you were doing maps
maps yeah you know this is honestly like
a lot of songs that were that were being
for me in high school that I really
enjoyed the IAEA's maps Postal Service
Postal Service
uh dissemination army mm-hmm
Beatles tune we did the Beatles to them
at once ha one of the first things that
you ever put on the internet was a
Coldplay tribute and that's when you
were going under the name breezy Lovejoy
[Music]
which do you like the woodsy regret more
ain't got no regrets man but damn man I
did not have to do a whole couple a
tribute bro that was extra his foot I
was really into Coldplay dog couldn't
tell me [ __ ] couldn't tell me they
weren't the best bro well now you know
when you got first put on the Coldplay
some y'all will open his [ __ ] man
all right you ready to move on my man
all right I'll be eating the whole nug
yes did it all right firewater
[Music]
oh just one is hot mm-hmm mm-hmm
yeah let's take a milk break so I'm no
music critics I won't do the disservice
of trying to explain your sound but I
think what people are drawn to is how
layered your music is which I think
speaks to how diverse your listening
habits are so what I want to do is pull
at the threat of some of your influences
to see what they mean to you is it true
that used to get in trouble in school
singing dr. Dre and Snoop songs at
show-and-tell yes and some teachers
didn't get it some teachers were cool
though they let me do marketing somebody
teaches in understand but some teachers
revert over just echoes like you were
supposed to bring something just follow
the rules bro
don't try to finesse it I knew every
word though I was like that's a Show and
Tell for your ass bro the whole thing in
nothing but a G thang top to bottom
chorus is holding a Dre day I was
reciting that was the only thing I cared
about going home locked myself in the
room and learning every single words to
my favorite song what can you tell me
about the role the st. Pauls Baptist
Church had in your musical yes not
Nana's got got everything I asked my
foundation man thank God for the church
I will just be a little [ __ ] you
know best musicians best singers
craziest people talk about punk shows I
should go crazy too but you talk about
black Baptist Southern Baptist Church to
that energy crazy uses like baby doing
circle fits in there too
[Music]
taking the whole we gotta keep it got to
keep it going
[Music]
type of [ __ ] I'm talking about
mm-hmm-hmm it's why we came here today
breakthroughs
[Music]
what's happening dead-ass yeah all right
Anderson we know that your West Coast
Ventura County to the core then even
your lyrics your music videos they're
full of all these references to
old-school California culture so what I
want to do is play a game called how
west coast is it I'll give you some
topics and you'll tell me if it's West
Coast kind of West Coast are totally
Fugazi okay okay El Camino is on
Dayton's
West Coast and and Dirty South yeah the
go Daytona's ma'am well traditional she
vintage cars muscle cars american-made
cars Fatburger I've heard that you have
a very controversial take on why that
burger out is better than in and out
west coast you can get more options you
can get a whole fried an egg on your
sheet relish mustard
you see I split the LA access start
coming out right now you [ __ ] diving you
get mustard relish Friday gluten-free
bun now mm-hmm
impossible burger which is that vegan
burger that tastes like a real murder
they didn't wanted to only but I wanted
to only spots festival squash you need
an impossible burger okay um ladies man
days on both sided by mustard
I said muster already you know they take
two hours to make one burger but it's
gonna be fire
what about horchata horchata sounds like
a Taurus watch out that horse touch'
okay Omar's horchata bachata yeah west
coast absolutely man
the bomber shot down with the cinnamon
and the Reisman and the ice that the
crushed ice let me get a gang of crushed
ice in my [ __ ]
that was coming in with a refill for
Anderson thank you I was like they're
gonna do me dirty not him you know
Anderson how are you doing I'm all right
I can't believe there's two more though
which was the last one we just say the
bomb the bomb yeah this some [ __ ] bender
can't be taking you know what for fun
one time it's chatting with Thundercat
and he was saying you know Zack Fox
mm-hmm they were you're saying that they
did Mad Dog 357 and then went to the yg
show on it yep and they said it was like
the biggest mistake ever they get a rush
on it
they like that Shane iax crazy sale of
night big bite tight lil bike hey hey
did you get a sign cheers Cheers we did
it
[Music]
robbed
how look on being read under the lights
looking better than when you walked in
here Anderson born again change man
mm-hmm updated my dad oh boy
son of a [ __ ] mm-hmm that's far yeah so
they're obviously a lot of elements to
your songwriting but not to be outdone
the music videos as well can you talk me
through the biggest professional
challenge and working with a live zebra
on the bubblin set first like you're
excited cuz you like down but I'm good
to see a zebra I've never been really
close to a zebra then they brought the
zebra out downtown you know cars are
honking they're excited to see a zebra
tube you know and the you know trainers
like you know you're good just don't
move your arms around because he'll
he'll go straight for your neck you know
I'm a rapper all right yeah you can tell
rap or not to move his hands when he
raps
the video comes out and you start seeing
all the great accolades you get then you
look in the comments and you just see
like why would you put the zebra to that
torture son of a [ __ ] you inhumane evil
and then I'm like damn I didn't think
about that I was just so caught up like
I'm so excited to see Zoomer I was
thinking about how to zebra felt you
know I didn't mean any harm by that you
know it's just like cause so excited
about a zebra but I probably won't do
that again I forgot to do it again I
can't I mean the [ __ ] man it's [ __ ]
hot ready to go with the ranch
all right Anderson
[Music]
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
and you don't have to if you don't want
to but
there it is that's good that's textbook
all right my man
prayer to the hot sauce gods it's going
down
what a ride it's been Anderson and man
thanks miss its logical time
[Music]
going back it's going down so bitter
all right Anderson here we are at the
top of spice mountain insides bubbling
tongues of blaze and over this journey
we've talked about your inspirational
upbringing your West Coast credentials
your many musical influences but one
thing we haven't heard is that great
voice of yours so now that we have a
trillion scovilles hitting that million
dollar voice what I want to do is go up
and down the hot sauce lineup and you
can just hit me with an ad-lib for each
sauce is it a yes loud or is it a buoy
and we'll start at the classic gotta
take it easy
the humble house I don't even remember
that I don't remember that I'll new home
remember that butterfly bakery Oh what
about the habanero mango yo let me tell
you so came up in this place I was
really really friendly but that chick
right there got me [ __ ] bug that [ __ ]
right there really for the public
los calientes baby I won't tell you
something yeah I got a chapter on ice
when you get home
at that little bit spice will be oh what
about the Assam yo remember the
firewater dabomb yes Lord X horoscope
it's close Polly desperately desperately
ausco and all that foil and the last tab
you know baby I was thinking like it's
so much talked about what she was gonna
do to me and all his sister days he was
gonna do when I got home but you know
when I got home I just feel like it was
all tacos or cat and um you know over
here would like to keep it 100 in my I
have to say it wasn't the best but it'll
do well we'll take it and look at you
Anderson pack all the way through the
hot wing gauntlet ten vegan wings up ten
vegan wings down and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you my friend this camera this
camera or this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
check it out I've just dropped a single
tints featuring Kendrick Lamar we
extended the summer for you
[ __ ] k the album's call oxley
dr. Dre mixed everything top to bottom
loudest [ __ ] tell them though man it's
like November 16th it's called Oxnard
dr. Dre ever heard of them it mixed the
whole thing nothing but legends on the
features am i right bringing it home
back home 805 stand up Oxnard I'm
bringing Trey Witten I'm bringing or
chop of cups
[Music]
good time it's a good job this is all
about the bomb yeah that's what you said
it gets a little squirrely right there
yeah I don't lie
Thanks so what they'll do Anderson real
quick cuz they'll do this slow zoom on
us look for the uh for the uh for the
opening sequence and then that'll be
that
okay what's going on spice Lords I know
you're wondering why is he shaking that
bottle why is he shaking that bottle
it's because I'm excited to announce
that the last dab products is available
now the last dab with chocolate pepper
ax and pepper X you've seen your
favorite celebrities dab and wings on
the show and now you can dab your wings
at home heat nice calm heat nice calm to
order who appreciates you spice Lords me